tu entends ce message puis l'année notre
tu peux trouver bientôt il n'y aurait
plus aucun enfant le gouvernement
n'avait pas peur de ceux qui étaient
morts ils avaient peur de nous car ceux
qui avaient survécu avait changé chaque
enfant se voit assigner une couleur qui
correspond aux troubles dont il est
atteint vers facultés intellectuelles
accru les bleus ou des capacités
télékinétiques les ors peuvent manipuler
l'électricité les rouges sont les plus
destructeurs et les oranges contrôler
les esprits
rubis tu es vraiment très rares et
celles qui sont prêts nous aider
ses doigts ne t'arrête pas je voulais
pas que vous ayez peur de moi plus
j'essaie de me contrôler
et plus je deviens toujours à 6 pts
je peux aider à maîtriser des facultés
pour que tu puisse s'en servir
[Musique]
on peut se battre
on n'est plus obligé de se cacher
je me battrai pour nous tous